[Music]
how are you happy Friday cristian cásseres greets
you with his news
now network in Spanish an outbreak of
positive cases of coronavirus is being
reported here in the state of nevada
for christmas and new year according to the
kobe 19 team of the  state 1,200 new
cases were reported yesterday and 47
more people died, these are the
highest figures since last January 7,
despite the fact that the cases of contagion
are decreasing, but the number of
deaths is still high.
The
sensor has been in operation for a week,
however, the site will be closed from
today until Sunday but promises to
open Monday with some changes. It is estimated
that more than 2,000 people are vaccinated
there each day. The
South Nevada Health District continues to remind the
community to make an appointment first
the school district of the record and is
looking for a solution to its
staff shortage a problem that it has been
fighting for some time yes yes this ti  Jan 269
fewer educators than due according to
reports this week The same report
revealed some solutions How to start
the hiring process earlier and
develop a system to increase
teacher diversity through
local universities
and Las Vegas residents' now  they will be able to
order alcohol online
starting sunday the new law was approved
by the councilman of las vegas with the
hope of helping restaurants and
businesses that are operating under months
of restrictions all businesses and
home services will need a
specific license by law before  to offer this
service and finally we take a
look at the conditions today it is expected
to be a cloudy day before the
arrival of an atmospheric disturbance
tonight that will also leave snow in the
line area temperatures will
reach 60 degrees and the course
of the  I work home tonight it will be
rainy remember to drive very
carefully I am cristian cas  beings with their
brief informative news now in Spanish
happy legs
[Music]